[Musique]
dans un mois c'est le réveillon de noël
c'est parfois un peu difficile de
patienter jusqu'au jour j
on peut donc écrire sa lettre au père
noël décorer son sapin et surtout le
rendez vous incontournable du matin
ouvrir une case de son calendrier de
l'avent mélanie vous aider si vous avez
décidé d'en fabriquer un avec un
matériel original certes avec des
chaussettes alors on a tous des
chaussettes qui se retrouve tout seul à
cause de la machine à laver qui fait
disparaître la copine ou parce que cette
fameuse copine s'est abîmé et pas
question d'éjecter c'est ce qu'a dit on
peut toujours s'en servir donc il nous
en faut 24
il faut aussi un petit peu de matériel
bonne foi peut mater avec quelques
petites choses parce que pour un pour
info pour cette activité je n'ai rien
acheté tous les éléments je les avais
déjà dans un malade d'activité j'ai pris
de la peinture des pinces à linge de la
colle des mouchoirs une aiguille du fils
et des étoiles que j'ai imprimé et une
fois que tout était rassemblée j'ai
choisi une chaussette blanche neutre
pour la rendre plus jolie et plus jolies
les choisit de la décollecte des étoiles
puisque avec des ciseaux j'ai découpé
une des étoiles que j'avais imprimés et
avec de la peinture j'ai fait une
première étoile en faisant le contour et
on peut aussi faire des étoiles plein en
se servant de la feuille comme un
pochoir
mais on peut aussi découpé coudre échos
les enfants qu'on sera en fin de compte
on peut laisser libre cours à son
imagination que c'est ça il ya 24
chaussettes donc on peut faire un peu
tout ce qu'on veut pour la deuxième fois
j'en ai choisi trois de chaussettes une
kim sert de base et deux autres dont
j'ai découpé les détails sur une
chaussette noire j'ai trouvé des petits
rectangles coup là je trouvais millions
ou j'ai donc isoler cette partie que
j'ai ensuite cousue sur ma chaussette
marron qui est au titre tout tristoune
et pour la décorer un peu plus on va le
voir à l'image là j'ai plutôt choisi de
récupérer la décoration hello kitty
d'une chaussette pour enfants que j'ai
aussi collé dessus et pour celle du 24
décembre alors une déco un peu
particulière oui c'est le dernier jour d
attente avant que le père noël
descendent par la cheminée
alors j'ai dit choisi moi de faire mon
propre papa noël en chaussettes
rien de plus simple une chaussette que
rouge sur laquelle j'ai collé des
morceaux de mouchoirs déchiré vous posez
vous pouvez aussi oser le faire avec du
coton des yeux et on est dessiné au
feutre et voilà le père noël pour former
son calendrier
alors des chiffres écrits sur du papier
donc le tout accroché à une corde alors
on va essayer de le montrer sans faire
tous tombés voilà donc ça donne ça le
calendrier de l'avent tout petit peu de
place pour l'installer sur le mur oui
forcément ou au dessus de la cheminée
voilà que ce sont les chaussettes de
noël merci beaucoup
mélanie pour votre idée du calendrier de
l'avent donc prêt à être installé dès la
semaine prochaine puisque la semaine
prochaine ce sera le 1er décembre
donc n'oubliez pas de le fabriquer ce
week-end merci beaucoup mélanie